DAVID JORDAN: Hello, and
welcome back to recitation.
In this question,
we're going to be
considering a
contour plot, which
is given to us as followed.
The values are not indicated.
So the first thing
that we want to do
is we want to identify--
on this contour plot,
there is a unique
saddle point, and we
want to label that
as point A, and there
are two points which are
either a maximum or a minimum.
We can't actually tell
because the labels aren't
on this contour
plot, but we want
to go ahead and label
those anyways: B and C.
So they're either
maxima or minima,
but we can still find them and
we can still identify them.
So that's the first
part of the problem.
The second part is, since this
doesn't have the values entered
onto the graph, we
want to consider
what possible configurations
could we have?
So the second question is:
can B and C both be maximal?
And can we have B
maximal but C minimal?
OK.
And then in each
of these two cases,
we want to sketch the 3D graph.
So why don't you take some
time to work this out.
Pause the video, and
we'll check back,
and I'll show you
how I solve this.
Hello, and welcome back.
So to get started, why don't
we answer the first question
by writing the points right
on our original graph.
So I'll just come over here.
Now, when we're looking
for a minimum or a maximum
on a contour plot,
you know, the thing
that we should keep in mind
is that a minimal or a maximal
always is going to be contained
in concentric contours that
are either approaching
the minimum from below
or-- excuse me-- approaching
the maximum from below
or the minimum from above.
And so if we look here, we
see that these rings start
to become concentric,
and somewhere in here,
there's got to be either
a maximum or a minimum.
Because, you know, inside
this little region here,
the function doesn't pass
through another contour plot,
so we have to find either
a maximum or a minimum
inside the innermost ring.
And similarly, we have to find
either a minimum or a maximum
here.
So let's just call this
one B and this one C. OK.
Now, we also have a saddle
point A in this problem,
and it's a little bit hard
to see in the contour plot.
I think it'll be a little
even clearer when we draw a 3D
graph, but basically
what's happening
is the fact that you
have these contours--
so this contour is, after
all, the same as that contour.
So the value of the function
here and here are the same,
and yet, if we
look at this point
and this point, the values,
they'll either go up or down.
We don't know.
Let's assume that they go up.
So here, in this direction,
the values are going up,
and in this
direction, the values
are determined by
this contour curve,
and so somewhere in
this middle region here,
there's got to be
a saddle point.
I think this'll be even
clearer when we draw our graph.
So we have a saddle point
A in the middle there.
And, in fact, this
is really-- this
is the general picture
of what a saddle point is
going to look like.
It's going to be when you have
two either maxima or minima
rising out, and
you have a contour
which is containing the
point in the middle.
So those are our
points A, B and C
that we're going to
be interested in.
So now, the second question
that we have to consider
is can B and C both be maximal?
And the third question is can
B be maximal and C minimal?
And actually, we'll answer
both of these questions
by just sketching an
example, so that's how will
we'll understand this.
So why don't we see if we
can sketch an example where
B and C are both maximal.
So here's the start of my
graph in three dimensions,
and if we want B and C
to both be maximal, then
let me go ahead and draw the
contour lines that we have.
So we have, first of
all, we had this one,
and then we had another
one, and then we had a peak,
and then we had a peak.
So if we want to draw
this in three dimensions,
then what we just
need to do is we just
need to follow these contour
plots up out of the plane
and into space.
So this goes up, and
then there's a maximum,
and then it comes back down
along the contour lines,
and then it goes back up,
and then it goes back down.
So that's just one
of the curves that
lies on the graph
of the function,
but then we need to flesh
out the contour lines, which,
they look like these
sort of rings here.
OK?
And so, indeed, we do see that
it's possible for both B and C
to be a maximal.
Here's an example
of such a thing.
And so here's our point
B, here's our point C,
and as promised, I think
it's much clearer now
how A becomes a saddle point.
Because you have these
two mountains rising up,
and the valley in between
them is necessarily
a little saddle here.
It increases in this
direction and it
decreases in this direction.
Now, for the second
one, we're asked
can B be maximal and
yet C be minimal?
And the answer is still yes.
And a nice way to think
about this problem,
to think about the graph
that I'm going to draw,
is imagine that we start
over here and we dig a hole,
and as we're digging, we
throw the dirt over behind us.
So we're going to have
a hole, a dip here,
and then we're going to
pile that hole up over here.
And so then--
Now, notice that both of
these that I've drawn,
if we don't label
the contour lines,
these have the
same contour plot,
because the
concentric rings on C,
which are telling us that
the function in increasing,
they're the same below,
because this is essentially
the same thing.
The concentric rings that on
this curve, on this surface,
were telling us that B
was a maximal point, now
the same rings are telling
us that B is a minimal point.
So this illustrates that
a contour plot is really--
doesn't tell you
everything about the graph
unless you actually label
the values of the contours.
So here we see
two examples where
the sort of global
behavior of B and C
are very different even though
they have the same contour
plot.
Now notice, in both cases,
A is a saddle point.
It's increasing in one direction
and decreasing in the other.
And I think I'll
leave it at that.